I'll give you another example it's in my
book in 1984 I was working really hard
and when your agent says you're so tired
you got to take a vacation
the agent makes 10% what you make when
you're aging tell you to take a vacation
you know that you're exhausted so I took
a vacation with Hawaii because he had
just get married and Tony stay at the
hotel there by myself I just wanted to
totally chill I was there for a week
that's well there's eight or two weeks I
said I want to come back to this place
never been it's beautiful so I got in
the plane all the island hoppers it goes
when I went to another into a ground
tour they get an ankle another island
way to Maui from the Big Island and it
was a twin-engine plane I was said that
the planes are going
shaking so don't stop didn't say to hell
and it stops oh so laughing you know the
fella says sit down sit down sit down
sit down sit down and buckle your seats
now usually in the movies when the
planes in trouble the pilot says ladies
and gentlemen
he can't be still over in control little
bit the pilot the powers doing help us
Jesus help us marry help us lord help us
Jesus help us marry help us Lord
the pilot look out the window I said
nobody showed up close to the BAM we
crash in the water no what is him soft
right when you hit the water from that
height well bam bam they tore the bolts
out of my seat and threw me forward the
scar is from that happening and when
that happened this it's hard to explain
but it's an out-of-body experience
something up there look down and what
sounds crazy but down at me and my seat
all the people bleeding the pilot and
everything okay so this thing I can't
explain what it was it's peaceful just
observing me how my wakes up this face
hit the dashboard of the plane everybody
else get up did it this thing in my body
merged back together
and they said Oh cuz I don't swim I said
I said it out loud you always wanted to
know how you're gonna die now you know
so I just sat there waiting for the
water's coming up boom boom boom bloods
coming up boom boom boom boom boom
polish people out take them to the wing
just hey you come on let's go let's go
let's go
I said I can't swim me says unbuckle
your seat okay I'm booked on my seat
take a light down that out I've thrown
up put it on your head
he gives me instructions pull of course
when I got this shorter like five chords
I looked down into a thousand I kept
pulling and pulling and pulling and
pulling and pulling and pulling nothing
after he left their places come to the
wing I said I don't see this come to the
wing I got the wing I'm standing there
and they all paddled away because they
olds family anything
gotta go five or six hundred feet away
he says jump jump undertow undertow I
said I can't swim he says jump nice to
myself what day I'll have to lose I'm
gonna die anyway so I jumped I forgot to
tie to life don't around my waist
because he had own he didn't pull a cord
as I I passed them he blew up I've
gotten tired of my waist and with that
once twice third time I came up life I'm
not exaggerating life doughnuts here
I put it around my head like a little
dog I do like this then I reach them
I recently turned around this big mouth
of water swallows the plane and takes it
under if I stayed on the wing I would
have died
I'm telling us all the truth I'm telling
you in the water ten minute passes
people are moaning and groaning lady
says look boats planes boats planes my
thought is you know before you die
because there's sharks in the world and
everything you have these delusional
thoughts and you think you see things
that's what she's doing right that's it
just boats planes boats planes take this
to Vegas you tell me the chances of this
happening twice a year
the Hawaii Fire Department since its
emergency rescue teams out to do
practices all different parts of the
ocean this day they were one half
nautical miles away from us they saw our
plane go in there were there in minutes
they took everybody out the water raft
us in blankets asked if the okay I
started driving us back to shore
I said next a pilot
six foot two or three Ichabod Crane blue
eyes I could see his face dark here with
white streaks through it sitting
he's shivering I'm shivering and I say
to him sir I don't wanna disturb you I
said but I was in shock you talked me
through getting out of the plane
you talked me into jumping off talked me
to paddling toward you saved my life and
I wanna I wanna thank you I cannot know
what to say
he looks at me and he says I appreciate
you saying that he said I'm not on the
Catholic I believe in Jesus Christ he
says I don't know what you believe in
he said but don't thank me thank that
turns away from me
the speck of my face grabs my shoulder
and starts crying like a baby
get back to shore people are in shock
because planes that crash in that where
they'll have survivors
I have no way of explaining it to say
that that's one of the day that I
realized there are things happening in
this universe that are far beyond my
intellect far beyond my intellect and I
had my two masters degrees and I was so
smart I can't even tell you how much I
learn from that experience I pictures on
a wall of my condo up there of that day
the newspaper I saved it and just framed
it I never want to forget it
it's just so it shaped my life between
those experiences and meditation to
shape my life and maybe understand that
you know